the militants met their end
in the early morning 18
hours after the killing began
the final battle for an upscale hotel
and office park
accompanied by gun bursts and sirens
in the sight of a badly injured kenyan
soldier
sent off for care there were survivors
some 50 people who were freed during the
last exchange of fire
we see the police say they are in panic
the police
themselves because they should against
them they don't know
because they don't recognize all the
police you have many police after
many people they have gun civil nobody
knows it was
general panic
the kenyan capital thrown into chaos by
extremists
from a group called al-shabab the
president
said the terrorists were eliminated but
few
will feel reassured this
is the moment the attack started a
suicide bomber is captured on cctv
as he stops in front of the hotel
restaurant
he's passed by a member of the public
who takes a quizzical look
seconds later he detonates the device
the attack was brazen and the target
was defenseless
soldiers and armed police officers were
called to the scene
as office staff and hotel guests begged
for protection
still no one could be sure of the
attacker's whereabouts
time member of the british sas also
joined the fight
21 people lost their lives in this
incident
including britain luke potter
and family members were asked to
identify their loved ones
at a city morgue
margaret lewich lost her son it's
difficult
not to have the opportunity to say
goodbye very
very difficult yes and it's uh
we're finding it's hard we've not yet
believed that he's gone
the authorities say they'll pursue all
those responsible
but that will provide little comfort
here
john sparks sky news in nairobi